this is the helipad on the top of the St
George's Hospital in Beirut
the time is just after six on an
uneventful Tuesday evening and one week
on although you know what's coming next
it is still shocking
down below the hospital's other 230
closed circuit cameras captured the
chaos
it's the first time this footage has
ever been shown
in the postnatal wars a nurse hears what
was the first small explosion she's
curious before realizing something
terrible is happening
disoriented she gets to her feet and
rushes to the babies in her care off
camera she takes them to safety
the babies were right here nurse Pamela
zanoon was in the ward above the
neonatal Intensive Care Unit they treat
premature babies
this video shows her working just
moments before the blast
she feels the first Tremor and then the
room collapses smoke rubble and fear
amazingly Pamela was barely scratched
but what happened after she fought her
way out of the wreckage is truly
astonishing
the other nurses were not very badly
they were very badly into it they were
all bleeding they were standing over
there and they looked at me and they
looked at them I was I started to scream
what what happened they just looked at
me this way and looked at each other
they were all bleeding they couldn't
even talk all the all the ceiling was on
the floor I grabbed the ceilings with my
hands and tried to pull them away just
to know where the babies were because
the incubators moved they weren't on the
same place I hold the three babies and
went through this door we needed to go
to the exit we couldn't find the exit we
used that the exit was on our left side
now there's nothing on our left side I
walked around five kilometers on the
street so I could get the babies to
another hospital
but you save them you saved everybody
wow
much of the hospital was wrecked
17 people were killed nurses patients
and visitors amongst the victims
but when you see this footage it's a
miracle the loss of life wasn't greater
in the main lobby people scatter and
then a blast wave of glass splintered
wood and Concrete
so it kind of blew inside and it hit me
on the side of my face Professor George
was in his clinic at the time he told me
he just finished a consultation had my
colleague not pick me up from here hey I
could have led to death who knows who
should be proud of what we've done
what this hospital did in eight hours
evacuating over 300 patients to safety
despite the lack of power and glass
everywhere and unsafe environment and no
resources is a miracle by itself and
speaks to the greatness of these people
many of the cameras around the hospital
stutter in the aftermath
but despite the glitching they still
record a city in panic and shock
a few minutes after the explosion
injured people from across the
neighborhood are running to the medical
center for help not knowing that it had
also become a casualty
never throughout its history was it shut
down completely like it is right now
so it's incumbent upon us all to get it
restarted this is a message that I
cannot over emphasize this is Who We Are
across Bay route you can find many
stories of heroism and bravery
but this is a place where the disease of
corruption never allowed a healthy state
to grow
and as it remembers its victims the
challenges of mending this fractured
City its politics and economy will take
years to overcome
Alex Rossi Sky News Beirut